IP lookups find longest prefixes. Let's suppose that we
want to represent a particular IP address as one
point in the space from zero to 2 to the 32 minus 1, or the range of all
32-byte IP addresses. Each prefix represents a smaller range
inside this larger range of 32-bit numbers. Obviously, this
is not to scale. Now these ranges, of course,
might be overlapping, as is shown here. And the idea
is that longest prefix match will match the
smallest prefix for which the IP address range
overlaps that of the specified IP address. So
longest prefix match is harder to perform than exact
match. For one, the destination IP address does
not indicate the length of the longest matching
prefix, so some algorithm needs to determine the
length of the longest matching prefix, which in this
case is 21. So we somehow need a way to search the
space of all prefix lengths, as well as prefixes of a given length.